comment on something like the ponies
okay how can I start doing that I feel
like I'm still think I still suck so
much that don't just my tribes gonna do
weirder
well the difference between the
choreographs UK and an actually get is
the actual bouquet is harmonizing Union
young energy doesn't do anything outside
of them okay what I what the beginner
tend to think is oh i bouncing back and
forth between the dressage pony who get
and someone who's countering techniques
things like that that's the wrong
spectrum okay this spectrum is not one
of between you know collusion and
contesting yin and Yan so when you look
at a new kid who is being corrected
rather than look at it from were they in
collusion or were they contesting look
just ask where was their yen where it
was supposed to be and they were young
or was it younger was put to be or was
in yet and you'll find well yes that was
what's the problem
okay there's no it's not that you can't
contest but in the fulfilment of
harmonizing yen and young just like Naga
hookah does no more nor no less than
what needs to be done okay and that's
kind of hard because harmonizing Union
Yong is an enlightened state that's why
it earlier this week we were talking
about decades decades for me kami
okay this is shoulder
to be internet if it's being pulled off
the communication has energy you're
coming up right which is very common to
asking that a lot just remember it's a
ten in ten means to press to press not
to pull so when you see that you have
somebody who is picturing a pain
compliance technique and the submission
the voluntary conscious submission of
the attacker this is not tactically so
we do not we do not give control to the
attacker on whether they will surrender
or not do you understand that so you see
this - in law enforcement a lot it's a
very very unsound thing it only works in
controlled environment and only with
very inexperienced practitioners because
they have not built up the flexibility
and the conditioning of the tissues
involved nor nor does the beginner
practitioner have that that resiliency
and that anti fragility that lets you
know the pain isn't going to make them
quit what does that have to do with
anything to get it so usually when
you're with the beginner you'll you'll
do all this kind of stuff and they tap
out and then you get a culture of of
people thinking oh this is a pain
compliance it's not a pain compliance
we're one I told you it was a training
it was a cultivation tool right and then
too I showed you that it's anatomically
geometrically working what does whether
it hurts it or not he cannot do anything
but feed the architecture that's pinning
them down right if you like this if you
are experiencing pain compliance then
categorize it as Who I am not
conditioned enough and I am still too
woozy okay so when I've seen some
demonstrations where you know the kids
are competitive my mind with holy cow
you can't sub that up right you can't
move where you need to move so have that
mindset
okay so don't pull and twist that does
not see anatomical architecture